and for Jake I'm so thankful when he
goes out to lunch with his ex and I find
out on Twitter looks like there's
trouble in paradise for Tana Mungo and
Jake Paul you of me here's what you need
to know Jake was spotted at a birthday
party with his ex-girlfriend Erica
Costel
later they were photographed having
lunch then on Sunday less than a month
after Jake and Tana tied the knot
there's my way
Tammy took to her Instagram story to
sing about her past and present love
life hola Ariana Grande's thank you next
the YouTube star replaced
Ahri's lyrics with her own and not so
subtly hinted at her hubby's lunch with
his ex even actually got married and for
Jake I'm so thankful when he goes out to
lunch with his ex and I find out on
Twitter okay so it sounds like the 21
year old learned about to get together
on the Internet
ouch she also references Bella Thorne
who she was in an open relationship with
for over a year
I never faked and Hunter Moreno
tannaz frequent collaborator with whom
she has told fans she had a complicated
on-and-off-again relationship I allowed
you to end things kidding me hunter
jaikant Anna said I do in Las Vegas on
July 23rd the two were supposed to jet
off to Europe for their honeymoon really
but Tiana explained to fans via social
media that she had a family emergency
and had to stay back two weeks after
their wild nuptials Tana admitted she
and Jake aren't legally married and to
everybody that's calling it fake because
we rushed into it or because I don't do
things traditionally because I wanted to
not do it legally but any wedding I have
if I had three more I think I really
wouldn't want to do it on paper because
I think that legally binding yourself to
someone takes away the love